in product updates bottom on to know
where Peter Parker goes next when you
know the he's involved on earth than the
next film
you know I'd be excited as a father than
to you know I mean for me I finished
shooting spider-man already asking me
questions to Kevin Feige what happens
next never tells me because you know I'm
terribly excited to find out and become
a rule of thumb there that no one tells
you anything because kind of okay though
it's great for me to play this character
is a real dream come true I mean I grew
up and who is my favorite character so
learning the ins and outs of spider-man
is is amazing can we talk about the new
suit
it's pretty happy with even just immense
you know but it's I mean even from the
trailer it looks pretty spectacular the
new suit shoes bubbles apparently know
to wear it did I was basically wearing
pajamas all the time while all these
guys look amazing in their costumes so I
was wearing a mocap suit but in the
trailers and it was amazing so believe
me I'm just as excited as you guys see
percent of the audience you've probably
got spider-man pajamas anyway yeah and
with this enormous cast if you have an
infinity over there any particular do
look at any of them behind me any
particular cast members you were really
looking forward to working with for the
first time
you know actually I've had a great
relationship with better they come about
better fix box they just sorry we had a
very unique experience as we were
filming two films at the same time
together so one day I'll be playing
Benedict Cumberbatch's assistant and the
photocurrent war and then the next day
we'd be fighting aliens in space so it
was a really strange way to make a film
so we became very close through that
process well that's the major thing that
they splitting your brain in half well
and what will you take away from this
particular experience of making infinity
war you know meeting new people make
some great phones became a part of
something that I've been a fan of since
actually kids so thanks to these two
right here you cast me in Civil War you
guys changed my life son thank you very
much
last time we saw Bucky he was in Canada
yes the end of that were ever in a ways
he's got a second chance of life you
know this has become his family that
kind of embraced in them and so it's
it's been good it's been it's been a
journey back to essentially what you
used to be um one of the kind of pivotal
things this story is just a relationship
between Bucky and Steve and something
that I I assume that we're going to see
part of or see it develop or see the
strength or the weakness of that that
relationship maybe in this way or all
the above yeah why not they want to like
every relationship yeah yeah the highs
of those yeah well I think at this point
it's sort of hard to you know in point
exactly there are more substantial
matters at hand such as you know the
villain that we've all got a face in the
spoon so I would say he's more in a
place of finding himself grateful that
he can be trusted
yeah and and show up to the cause and
for for you to not to in terms of having
that opportunity to play both a villain
and a heel is that an interesting thing
in terms of the arc of a character
yeah oh yes I mean you know it's been a
nice thing about the character then you
know you sort of had the same river in
these days
always going you know in between you
never really know where he's gonna end
up and and that's always been fun for me
you know just just kind of having a bit
of a guessing game I guess and what
about walking with the rooster brothers
as well I'm not this particularly well I
found me you know I they they've been
with me well I've been with them for the
last three movies and you know they
they've always ground of the story and
you know in one way and so I mean they
got my heart but the end in terms of
when you look back to when Loki was
first introduced to the world you know
omens what do you remember about that
time one Monday morning I came back and
Ken said to me would you do the weekend
SS so this film Iron Man it's really
great you know I am doubting yeah and
then I said you worked with him with
Robert Altman and we had this
conversation up down his Union and then
a year later we were making Thor
together and both of us felt like we had
won the lottery because we were in this
world this is a new world and Kevin
Feige the president of our studios said
to me when he was congratulating me on
getting the part he said I want to talk
to you about the Avengers and I went I'm
still getting to grips with Thor what
were the Avengers and he told me this
dream about the new universe that he was
building of all these characters from
the comic books and it was going to be a
cinematic universe to the mirror the
comic books I think that's amazing and
now 10 years later and I'm still here
[Applause]
infinity war than Mikey Thomas and Loki
such a memorable villain
Jessica Enochian Thanos have history
well I wanted to ask if what makes a
good villain and whether you passed that
any advisor to wealth Alice is played by
Josh Brolin you know advice for me
actually he if he were here he was I
think having the time of his life on on
this huge enjoyed it more than anything
else he'd ever done and he said it's
worth with sincerity he said this is
like going back to drama school I love
Dayton I'm at the vanguard of a new
technology I think he was kind of taking
the the sort of like he felt like the
only one you know that fan also go to
his head yeah it's what's interesting
about this film is for those of you who
may remember in Avengers 1 Loki arrives
on earth with the scepter which is which
contains one of the Infinity stones
which Stannis needs to collect or used
to contain until resided in the head of
very fine Paul Bettany and and also the
tesseract is another one the space stone
and Loki and the tesseract also go way
back and some of you seen the trailer so
one spoiling anything I think even I've
been I think Loki in my head is is he's
forgotten his cards at home and it
doesn't have any cash and someone said
that I need you've bought the event just
beat sir what have you gotten is like
now the Tesla don't tell me you haven't
sat at home it done spider-man hundred
ones to be very judged what's America go
see huge congratulations on Black
Panther on your Sheree just really it
really occurred to a huge fan favorite
what do you love about her man I just
love the fact that she's just so
relatable you know it's like every
little sister that's in you know a
household that's nagging at you but
she's super intelligent she cares about
people and she just wants to help out at
last thinking on her brother so just to
see the love and the reception that's
been it's been a blessing and really
cool so thank you guys to be involved in
in this Avengers film and knowing that
the shoes part of that journey and where
she would go but listen I was just
minding my own business trying to finish
off like them as you do and then the
exact marvels it's like we need to need
to talk to you and I thought damn it
like what did I do that I leaked
[Music]
oh did I ask you something you know
that's it I take extra food at lunchtime
look I don't look it but I do
what did I do and they caught on the
phone and they're like I'm gonna be in
the next Avengers oh I like just like
that what about the additional process
you know do I have to like do something
leap some lines they're like no kid just
be in the film say yes and I'll see you
I'll see you in June and then I met the
brothers and they were just like yeah
this is your lab is what you're doing
and it was just amazing so I'm so
grateful to be a part of it we're so
excited to see shoes next door aren't we
[Applause]
you talked to me a little bit about your
character and how she's taking this
journey through you know the film since
we first met her a lot of loss and and
now with the surrogate Avengers family
and she is found a partner and
and they gonna have his little secret
journey between civil war and war I
would ask you if the loves reciprocated
the whole talked about oh oh it's not
good each edge away No beyond
reciprocally an other brilliant thing
about the cars is how she comes to
chance' but it was control of house
which is a great journey for a character
to take he's not being a fun thing to
kind of explore as well with them yeah
it's been really great and then every
every film we did we take it to a
different level and so this one we
worked a lot more at the stunt team a
lot more factual flying flying with
Paul's side by side colliding in space I
mean on space space just like this green
screen but it's been a lot of it's been
a lot of fun every one every every new
film yeah I found them at last
and I've actually learned something new
in each experience as well absolutely
yeah there's always there's a different
kind of stakes to this film than the
others and that's exciting I like him
everybody missed again was really I also
don't know some edited out in such a
significant way and so like even if I
say something it's not actually there
but I'm here now so I wonder what it's
been like for you to kind of strap on
that coolant of anything
you are so you know in thor ragnarok is
well why you know I'm ready joy I'm
gonna enjoy playing him so it was fun to
be back in the cozy and still the old
cloak a new Joker own trailer and ride
is about when it can now cigars and you
know what it needs me lunch it living
the treating that cloak is no it's great
fun we have receives on the first film
as well as the bit I didn't reckon or so
it was the genuine thrill to sort of go
back um for that and yeah fitting into
this giant mosaic is kind of awesome the
biblical science is terrifying but
brilliance and yeah you feel like a new
view all over again certainly this is
one of the most complicated movies ever
made in many ways but you know I think
all of us appreciated what a special
opportunity this was what a unique
opportunity this was I mean no one has
ever seen a film like this no one has
ever seen this number of loved
characters in a single film with this
caliber of cast and that's really what
drove all of us and and I think
everybody brought their best
collaborative energy to the project
everybody sacrificed art for the project
it's not only important to us it's
important to audiences and everybody
rose to the cause how do you want
finalists to feel after they've seen
this though hmm that's a good question
I think we want them to to feel
satisfied with storytelling mm-hmm and
to feel a complex array of emotions
I just want a couple of emotions that
you might think we might feel is it that
sound a complex array of emotions it's
certainly going to be a lot of fun when
you put all these characters together
yeah the the movie the theme of the
movie is about what does it cost to be
hero in a complicated world and does the
cost of you know there's a value of
doing what's right outweigh the cost and
I think it's important message in this
film I mean it's important of the world
today and you know I think it's going to
be really interesting arrived for
everyone well I think it's one of the
many reasons that you know the success
story of 10 you is 19 phones it's just
that the tool that these thumbs brought
right from the start in terms of they
just give you we talk about a mixed
array of emotions the tone does that
brilliantly and stuff was that something
that was easy to get for this with there
being so many characters and stories to
tell
yeah you know Joe and I have always
thought of ourselves and our creative
processes like you know akin to like
being mad scientists you know you like
to take disparate elements and smash
them together and see what happens and
that's part of the thrill of the
creative process and certainly we had
that opportunity on this filament in in
one ways it can be looked at as a
creative challenge but it's also the
creative up side and being able to pull
from care from characters that have such
a wide variety of tones films that have
such a wide variety of tones and
figuring out how they live in the same
space together what happens when you
push them together I mean that's why
this film was such an intense
collaborative processes and that's why
we had to rely so much upon the actors
in terms of what their instincts were
what their sensibilities were how would
they behave when they met each other for
the first time even though they were
coming from places that were so
different not just on a narrative level
but I'm a tonal stylistic level so it
was a complex process but I think that
when it went all mixed together it makes
for a pretty wonderful stew in
particular on infinity war techhobo TV
was working on Thor rag
at the exact same time that we were
shooting and Ryan Coogler was there
working black panther at the exact same
time so we had to stay in constant
contact with type Dan Ryan about those
two films because you know they were
like what's going in a completely
different direction with Thor and Black
Panther Ron was developing a whole new
universe so it was important that we
stay in contact so we text each other
call each other you know tyka came down
Atlanta where I was shooting across town
from us we would drive over and see his
sets and look at the production side and
talk about where was going so so that we
could truthfully and interpret the both
those universes Scotland does double
duty of the movie it plays as Scotland
as at borough itself and it also has
such a fantastic landscape and field
that we used it for other locations of
the universe as well so it just it just
afforded us a wide range of looks and
places that we could create out of what
existed there there's a very compelling
scene with vision and Scarlet Witch that
we really wanted the tone of a Edinburgh
for it's a backdrop to the scene and
you'll understand me season my way going
I wanna run down quickly the rest of the
team if that's alright before we move on
and get closer to show these guys this
footage but and Sebastian and to
everybody what's this Johnny that you've
been on with these amazing cup of people
for however long that is the what's the
thing that you've taken away from it
would you say to this point I mean
probably have no expectations if that's
even possible you know it's just when we
are here you're always sort of
surprising kind of yourself and the
outcome becomes all kinds of different
things I think for me at least I've
always just tried to be open and look
about and really take in the moment
because I as I keep reiterating over and
over I do feel
remember these movies for very long time
Elizabeth a sense of community
the feels nice to return to the same
same gang over no hurt Emma I hope I
gotta keep doing it's really it's a
great group of people we got to work
with Oh what about Fiza box-office bombs
same that's its friendship in films
usually you're just working with you
know new people every every time its
feet returning to the same people that
know your [ __ ] hey you can't get
away with it we've all gone through
real-life stuff together it's been it's
been a real you know real privilege I
think the Marvel Universe an incredibly
generous to me and I feel in the ten
years I've been doing it which is almost
a quarter of my life how generous the
films are and the studio is to the
audience and I feel so grateful I you
know they are superhero films but they
but goodness always wins out in the end
and I think that's a wonderful it's a
wonderful message it the goodness
goodness wins out in the end
thank you Benedict do sir I mean
everything has been said you know the
community it's lovely doing something
that's long form where you return to
familiar places or character or the
people you work with the family
community of Marvel added by Kevin
Libyans Victoria and you know I agree
you learn you learn from your peers you
learn from people younger a Tom actually
and and older and everyone in between
it's it's a fascinating culture to be
part of and we all come from different
careers of different places and
different levels but this is sort of it
feels like a sort of school outing the
treat you know it feels like a real
treat to be part of this
you